every Friday for the last year they've
been demanding an overhaul live
Algeria's entire political establishment
many Algerians say they feel betrayed by
their political elite and have lost
trust in the government we will remove
this regime from its roots this country
belongs to the people not to the thieves
and gangs this country is for Algerians
Algeria's political crisis began last
february when president abdul aziz buta
flicker announced he wanted a fifth term
in office the 82 year old had ruled for
20 years but was rarely seen in public
since suffering a stroke in 2013 after
weeks of protests calling for him to
step down the army withdrew its support
Algeria's longest-serving president
eventually resigned the Speaker of the
upper house of parliament abdel kader
bin Saleh was appointed interim
president but faced a daunting task
which africa's replacement was accused
of corruption vote rigging and poor
governance and seen by many Algerians as
belonging to the same elite when Saleh
called for unity as well as transparent
and fair elections but discontent
continued with protesters determined to
push for genuine change the presidential
election originally scheduled for last
July finally happened in December and
was boycotted by many Algerians millions
described the election as a sham and
less than 40 percent of the 24 million
eligible voters took part
the election was won by Abdul Majid
tabooed a former prime minister the
military-backed interim government hoped
he would end months of protests so far
that hasn't happened 58 years after
independence from France many Algerians
say they're still fighting for freedom
they want a clean sweep of the political
establishment and a national unity
government to bring democracy Victoria
Gaytan be al Jazeera